i'm so excited we have kendrick perkins
on the show today there's a lot to get
into with kendrick perkins um
i want to start with the football stuff
though kendrick because tj was talking
about
how he's getting emotional seeing the
guys from his childhood get inducted
you've had some of your teammates now
inducted into the naismith basketball
hall of fame
as a football guy a texas guy what's it
like for you to watch
these ceremonies and these these men who
you
admired for years getting shrined into
their respective hall of fames
well i mean you gotta you gotta
understand this is
when you enter the hall of fame that's
the the lead of the elite
and you know making it in a professional
sport is one thing
but being an all-time great and labeled
as an all-time great and actually
mastering the craft and and over
achieving
to the max where you get to get inducted
into the hall of fame that's on another
level
and you happen to see anybody anybody
whether
it was your opponent that you played
against whether it was a guy you watched
in another sport
when you go up there and you watch those
guys and you watch
those guys shed those tears a lot of
those tears
are not because you know it's 20 percent
of that is happiness right
but then you have 80 percent of that
they start to think back and reflect
back on their life and the sacrificing
that they had to do and everything that
they had to do to get to that point
and so when you watch it it's a
beautiful thing to see at any level
kendrick perkins joins the show espn's
hoop streams
you know of course is big perk and and
kendrick
you talk about the you know the uh the
emotion
that these men have when they're
inducted into the hall of fame
are you familiar with the new trend
that's happening around the olympics
when olympic athletes win gold medals
they just call you out and they just
shout you out and they curse you out
do you think this is going to catch on
is this going to be a trend we're going
to see in future olympics
uh hey you know what look when you had
doubt in your own head
and and and look look sorry look i
apologize to the world
if i just had if i'm because i'm small
right because i'm small because
the dream teams of the past and the
the kobe bryant olympic teams and
carmelo anthony olympic teams
won in great fashion excuse me if for
having high expectations for our country
right it's one thing to go win it but
here's the thing right
that just goes to show you that i got a
lot of real estate and a lot of these
guys here
and they're just watching me and i got
five thousand square foot and they ten
thousand square foot
uh palaces with a bedroom and everything
matter of fact they serving me breath
was in bed right now so
it's a good thing i'm happy that the
guys actually won
because i was rooting for them but you
know here's the thing
throughout the time that they were
playing it's okay for us
as americans to be concerned
right because they wasn't playing the
best of basketball
and we were used to we were accustomed
to seeing
a certain type of men's a team usa men's
basketball team
and just because we have concerns
doesn't mean that we were
doubting them or not wanting them to win
for our country
so you know at the end of the day man
you know you let them enjoy their moment
you let them do what they do it's all
fun it's all good
nba champion kendrick perkins joins the
show espn hooves stream's co-host
alongside cassidy hubbard
currently calling us from inside
draymond green's head where he's having
breakfast in bed
tj said the best eggs he ever had were
at four in the morning at puff daddy's
house in miami where the best scrambled
eggs you ever had
[Laughter]
make sure i just make sure you add a
little cheese on it hey perk you know
there was cheese on them eggs
it gotta be
[Laughter]
kendrick as as someone who is now
calling
you know these games or analyzing these
games or looking at the league
differently
has it changed your relationship with
basketball have you noticed that you
look at basketball different from being
a player
to now being an announcer well well no
not really because
you know any guy that any guy that
that that knows me or or that was a
teammate of mine
they know that i was always a fan of
basketball
and they always used to say man watch
something else on tv
i would literally go home and watch all
different games i would have four tvs on
watching
four different games on league passes so
i
always value games i always value other
players
that wasn't superstars and so now
being away from the game and in my new
career
the only thing i look at differently now
is that i look at the superstars
differently
and i watch watch how they are able to
carry their team and
things to that nature that's the only
thing that is different because
while i was on the while i was playing
basketball i always knew what superstars
could do it was capable of doing for us
have a huge night
but now i watch the others the others
that don't get the recognition
guys like pj tucker who could have zero
points
you know in the game six of the finals
and winning championship
playing 33 minutes into the into the
outside world
it looked like he was a non-factor but a
guy like myself
i saw the plays that he was making i
started the extra possessions that he
was getting the charges that he was
taking
doing making the winning plays that
didn't show up in the stat sheet
kendrick perkins joins the show espn
co-host of hoop streams and
you know him of course uh on twitter
he's always telling you to carry on
sharing his two cents
[Laughter]
[Music]
uh perk you know when i when i
think about this time in the basketball
season this is a little window right
here
you know we just got blessed with the
olympics summer league's kicking back up
but there's a little time here
where you know besides the drew league
or hoops in the sun or dikeman and stuff
you got to really search for basketball
what's in your netflix queue what are
you watching besides hoops i feel like
you
go deep down the rabbit hole on a
particular series are you a big
binge watcher perk well well i'm not you
know
you know to be honest look let me let me
tell you this
i'm a i'm a big i'm a huge fan
of animals right and so
some of my favorite shows may blow your
mind away like
i'm i'm a i watch a show called swamp
people
where they go out and kill alligators
for in louisiana
right and i watch a show called wicked
tuna
i watch i watch monster fish those are
the things that i love watching i'm big
on the discovery channel i'm big on
like watching stuff about animals and
things in other countries
like i'm not big on you know i don't do
i don't do other things like i'm not big
on reality tv
i'm not big on you know uh
these these new look these new little
series that's out
like i'm more of a boring type guy like
i like real
life things i have so many questions now
can you
open
finale tonight that's not absolutely not
that's animals in the wild what do you
mean that's animals in the wild
animals mating in the wild yeah
absolutely i'm watching
i'm watching like you know like on swan
people i'm watching this woman and her
17-year-old daughter ride through the
everglades of
ride through the everglades of uh you
know
uh louisiana by themselves while they
uh putting up lines to hunt alligators
to
to provide for their family and make
income those are things that i watch
kendrick perkins joins the show ben
line's in for rich on the rich eisen
show kendrick what's and
what's one animal that people might
think is cute and cuddly but is a
is far more vicious and ferocious
you said when i'm so i couldn't eat is
there an animal out there that people
think
is cute and cuddly has a reputation for
being sweet but actually
is a killer and is ferocious and we
should be aware of
well i mean you know i only watch the
animals that's ferocious
i don't know i don't know what animals
out there that's like
that i would consider cute and cuddly
but i only watch the ferocious ones i'm
watching great white
tiger sharks you know things that's in
the water
i'm watching those type of things i'm
watching you know like i said
alligator hunting i'm watching guys
raffle snakes that's my type of thing i
need something that's gonna
make me stay up at night now i had the
privilege of interviewing dwight howard
at his home once and he has about 12 or
13 exotic snakes uh who do you think
would be a good snake wrestler in the
nba
um robin dwight howard because i mean
you know him uh or robert uh cousins
because those are the two guys that
actually
those are the two guys that actually own
snakes
so i would have to give it to them
robert covington
snake owner didn't know that about
covington thanks for making our show
smarter today perk i appreciate it you
mentioned your love of animals in the
water
do you go in the water are you afraid to
swim in the ocean because of your
knowledge now of sharks
absolutely not matter of fact one thing
that i have on my bucket list
is to go and die and get in the cage
and go actually out there off the coast
of california
right in the pacific ocean and go out
there and look at those great whites
so that's one of the things i have on my
bucket list is to get in the cage
and actually get dropped in the water i
hope that the line not popular because i
am
about 75 pounds overweight since i
started since i stopped playing
so hopefully i could get that done but
that's on my bucket list right there but
look i'm telling you listen if i wasn't
a professional basketball player i'd be
a professional swimmer
you can't keep me out the water the
ocean the swimming pools
creeks whatever it may be put me in the
water and i'm a flourish whale
kendrick perkins joining the show i have
so many more questions how much time do
we have on this show
now brockman i i don't know an actual
basketball question though perk like
what are the celtics doing like
oh no get out of here
i want a real question what are the
celtics doing
uh yeah yo listen i have the same
uh questions myself and look you know i
like the addition of al horford
um i really thought that the celtics
should have pursued
spencer dinwiddie in my opinion i
thought he would have been a perfect
match
to go alongside jason tatum and jaylen
brown but they didn't get it done
i'm hearing rumors of dennis schruter i
don't know how well that fits
but i do know one thing peyton preachers
should not be playing summer league okay
he's past that this guy is a rotational
player
unless he wanted to play but i will say
this
you know the celtics don't have that
many options to
to choose from and by the way
the eastern conference is getting better
you look at the miami heat they got
better the atlanta hawks got better
uh the brooklyn nets are obviously
they're the champions
and the milwaukee books obviously there
you you you know teams are getting
better the knicks got better like
i'm just waiting on the celtics to
actually get
better we got we only have time yeah
sorry sorry questions
so we don't need to ask about basketball
let's talk adventuring with kendrick
perkins
kendrick my dad ran with the bulls in
pamplona is that on your bucket list
as a country boy growing up in beaumont
texas i actually know how dangerous
bulls
are and i know one thing from a guy that
went cow tipping a couple times as a
youngster
bulls and cows are something that you
want to stay far away from
as possible appreciate the advice there
kendrick thank you so much for joining
the show and if you ever want to talk
adventuring
or out in the wild or any of this stuff
please please call back
we will always accept the call i
appreciate it i thank you thank you
fellow thanks for having me
this is on the bucket list a big perfect
question if you ever get the chance to
have scrambled eggs at daddy's house i'm
telling you
don't forget the cheese might have some
grits too perk you know we do
so let's get it
i feel like a discovery show just like
traveling the globe
uh we come up with a lot of great shows
on this show i'm very into that boris
diaz turned into quite the adventurer
you can look up a video of boris sailing
across the train
making the trans-atlantic sail uh
looking at all the whales
on his youtube boris diaz has become an
adventurer
imagine boris and perk you got this
french guy
who loves espresso and wildlife
photography
then you got a big perk from beaumont
texas who's
eating bed and breakfast and inside your
head i'm watching that show
i'm watching watching every episode
that's a great job i wouldn't have peg
big perk as like a water guy just he
says he loves it
olympics said you can't keep him out of
a creek i think he said
creeks lakes ponds there's just a body
of water perks up
so much happening ah that's my kind of
interview man what are the celtics going
to do in free agents
no perkins wants to go free diving with
sharks
no i needed to be talked off oh my god
are you just watching
wildlife videos with perk as you study
how a jaguar hunts its prey
it's amazing should he be the new voice
of those uh earth
shows instead instead of david attleboro
that's so good yes
planet earth narrated by kendrick
perkins like david attleboro
fine you're out perks in hey you watched
all the way to the end thanks for that
watch more right here